JOINING ME NOW IS CNN
COUNTERTERRORISM ANALYST AND
FORMER FBI SENIOR INTELLIGENCE
ADVISER PHIL MUDD.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES WHEN
PEOPLE LIKE THAT FLORIDA STATE
REPRESENTATIVE GO OUT THERE AND
TRASH THE INTEGRITY OF THE FBI.
I KNOW YOU SAID THE OTHER DAY
YOU RECEIVED ONE OF THE MOST
MALICIOUS THREATS YOU'VE EVER
READ ALL BECAUSE OF YOUR
COMMENTARY ABOUT THIS SEARCH.
WE'VE SEEN TIME AND AGAIN
EXAMPLES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DAYS OF THIS ALARMING LEVEL OF
THREATS AND HEIGHTENED RHETORIC
IN RESPONSE TO THAT SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT.
THE FIRST WOULD BE THREATS TO
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO HAPPEN TO
BE FBI EMPLOYEES.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
CINCINNATI AND YOU'VE SEEN
REPORTS TODAY, OF ARMED
INDIVIDUALS OUTSIDE THE OFFICE
IN PHOENIX, THIS IS A NUMBERS
GAME, JIM.
IF POLITICIANS START TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO COMMIT ACTS
OF VIOLENCE AGAINST THE FBI,
EVEN IF YOU SAY DEFUND THE FBI,
THERE IS A VIOLENT FRINGE THAT
WILL SAY I WANT TO TAKE ACTION.
THERE MIGHT BE 100TH OF 1% OF
THE FRINGE WHO SAY THAT MEANS I
SHOULD COMMIT AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE.
MAN, THE FBI IS AN OPEN
ORGANIZATION.
I SERVED AT BOTH THE CIA AND THE
FBI.
THE CIA WAS CLOSED THE FBI IS
OPEN.
THOSE OFFICES ARE PUBLIC
FACILITIES.
THOSE OFFICES INTERACT WITH THE
PUBLIC.
IF 0.001% OF THE POPULATION SAYS
I NEED TO COMMIT AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE THE FBI EMPLOYEES ARE
UNDER THREAT.
LET ME CLOSE WITH ONE OTHER
ISSUE ON DE FUNDING.
IF YOU THINK THAT STATE AND
LOCAL POLICE CAN FOLLOW THE
CHINESE, THE IRANIANS, THE
RUSSIANS, FOLLOW ONE OF THE MOST
HORRIFIC THINGS IN AMERICA, THAT
IS CYBER PORNOGRAPHY AGAINST
INFANTS, IF YOU THINK THEY CAN
FOLLOW WHITE COLLAR CRIME,
MORTGAGE FRAUD, THAT IS NOT A
STATE AND LOCAL PROBLEM.
YOU MAY OBJECT TO WHAT HAPPENED
AT MAR-A-LAGO BUT IF YOU SAY
DEFUND THE FBI LET YOUR KID BE
ABUSED BY AN ADULT.
THAT'S WHAT THE FBI DOES.
GOOD LUCK, JIM.
>> YEAH.
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
IT IS NOT A REALISTIC PROPOSAL.
AND IT SEEMS TO BE MADE WHEN
DONALD TRUMP GETS HIMSELF INTO
HOT WATER.
THAT IS WHEN THEY WANT TO GO
AFTER FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SPEAKING OF WHICH, WE KNOW
THAT THE UNREDACTED SEARCH
WARRANT WAS LEAKED.
MANY OF THE NAMES OF THE AGENTS
INVOLVED ARE OUT THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM YOUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THEY CONDUCT A SEARCH
LIKE THIS, YOU KNOW, THIS GETS
LEAKED.
AND THE AGENTS' NAMES AND SO ON,
IT GETS DOCKSED.
>> LET ME STEP YOU THROUGH WHAT
HAPPENS.
YOU HAVE TO GO HOME TO YOUR
SPOUSE OR GIRLFRIEND AND YOUR
CHILDREN AND YOU TELL THEM MY
NAME IS LEAK AND WHOEVER WANTS
TO COMMIT AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
MIGHT COME TO YOUR HOME.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO YOUR WORKPLACE
AND SAY SHOULD WE STAY HOME AND
OUR KIDS ARE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL.
IT IS AUGUST.
WHAT DO I DO?
WILL YOU PROVIDE ME WITH
SECURITY?
WILL THE GOVERNMENT PROVIDE
HOW LONG WILL THEY PROVIDE IT
FOR?
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO COMMIT AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST AN FBI AGENT.
I WOULD ASK THEM TO CONSIDER.
DO YOU WANT TO WALK HOME TO YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR SPOUSE AND SAY,
LOOK OVER YOUR SHOULDER WHEN YOU
GO TO THE GROCERY STORE AND
ENSURE THAT YOU DON'T ANSWER THE
DOOR?
IT'S THAT SIMPLE, JIM, THAT
SIMPLE.
>> YEAH.
AND THE MOTIVE HERE IS
INTIMIDATION.
THEY WANT TO INTIMIDATE PEOPLE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING.
IT IS NOT JUST THE THREATS TO
THE FBI.
THERE'S BEEN AN UPTICK IN
VIOLENT RHETORIC ONLINE SINCE
THE SEARCH INCLUDING PHRASES
LIKE LOCK AND LOAD, ANOTHER SAID
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND, QUOTE, NEEDS TO BE
ASSASSINATED SIMPLE AS THAT.
ANOTHER SAID, KILL ALL FEDS.
A LOT OF THIS, PHIL, REMINDS ME
OF THE OVER HEATED RHETORIC, THE
INCENDIARY RHETORIC WE SAW IN
THE RUN UP TO JANUARY 6th.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU THAT WE
MIGHT SEE ANOTHER SPASM OF RIGHT
WING, DOMESTIC TERRORISM IN THIS
COUNTRY LIKE WE SAW ON JANUARY
6th?
>> I MEAN, I'M LOOKING AT THIS
TODAY AND I'M SURPRISED.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
GOTTEN THIS QUESTION.
I'M SURPRISED THIS QUESTION
ISN'T COMING UP MORE OFTEN FOR A
SIMPLE REASON.
WHEN I FOLLOWED EXTREMISTS
OVERSEAS I NEVER ANTICIPATED WE
WOULD SEE THIS IN AMERICA.
WE ARE.
EXTREMISTS OVERSEAS IN SOME WAYS
HAVE SIMILARITIES TO WHAT WE SEE
IN THIS INSTANCE.
THAT IS THEY REQUIRE LEADERSHIP
TO TELL THEM THAT WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING IS OKAY.
THEY REQUIRE VALIDATION FROM
THAT LEADERSHIP TO SUGGEST TO
THEM THAT VIOLENCE IS OKAY.
WE SAW THAT BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RALLY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SENDS A NOTE EVIDENTLY
ACCORDING TO NEWS REPORTS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEFORE, EARLY
THIS WEEK, SAYING, THE COUNTRY
IS IN TROUBLE.
IS THERE ANYTHING I CAN DO TO
HELP?
AFTER THE RAID THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SAYS, THIS IS A FRAUD.
THIS IS A HOAX.
SOME OF THAT STUFF MIGHT HAVE
BEEN PLANTED.
THE SAME THING THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE JANUARY 6th IS HAPPENING
TODAY.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU AS WE SAW
IN PHOENIX IN THE PAST 24 HOURS
OUTSIDE THE FBI OFFICE, PEOPLE
WITH AR-15s IN CAMO ARE GOING TO
SAY I'M GOING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
THAT IS DANGEROUS.
I THINK WE'LL SEE ANOTHER
CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
I'M NOT SURE BUT I THINK SO.
>> IT'S ALL BECAUSE TRUMP CAN'T
HANDLE THE SCRUTINY.
HE CAN'T HANDLE BEING THE
SUBJECT OF AN INVESTIGATION.
AND HE LASHES OUT BY DECLARING
AN ENEMY WHETHER IT IS THE PRESS
OR PEOPLE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SO ON.
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO BE A
RECURRING PATTERN.
HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
>> IT IS.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THIS ONE WAY IF
YOU'RE A STANDARD PRESIDENT.
MOST OF THE PRESIDENTS I DEALT
WITH OR MY FRIENDS DEALT WITH
THEY WOULD GO DOWN AND BRIEF A
PRESIDENT.
MOST PRESIDENTS WOULD SAY I
DON'T WANT ANYTHING SECRET,
TOP-SECRET, OR CONFIDENTIAL IN
MY HOUSE.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
THIS PRESIDENT SAYS IT'S OKAY.
HE COULD HAVE SAID, HE COULD
HAVE SAID, I'M SORRY.
GET IT OUT OF HERE.
I'M SURE THE FBI WOULD HAVE SAID
WE DON'T WANT ANY PROBLEMS.
WE'LL REMOVE THE BOXES AND
SECURE THEM.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEE THIS
INFORMATION IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
RETURN IT TO YOU.
I SUSPECT THAT THE EXPLANATION
FOR WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS MORE
NEFARIOUS.
YOU COULD HAVE A SIMPLE
EXPLANATION THAT SAYS THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T CARE WHAT IS
ON THE COMPOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
YOU COULD HAVE A MORE COMPLEX
EXPLANATION THAT SAYS THIS IS
GOOD FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE IS GOING TO SAY THE DEEP
STATE IS COMING AFTER ME.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE I'M A
VICTIM.
HE IS GOING TO PLAY THIS GOING
INTO ANOTHER ELECTION CAMPAIGN.
NATIONAL SECURITY, JIM, USED TO
STOP THE AMERICAN SHORELINE.
IT NO LONGER DOES.
IT'S PART OF AMERICAN ELECTORAL
CAMPAIGNS.
THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE.
>> THE QUESTION HAS TO BE, OR
OFFERED EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE AS
TO WHY THEY'RE THERE BUT HE HAS
NOT EXPLAINED, HIS PEOPLE HAVE
NOT EXPLAINED WHY DOES HE HAVE
THAT STUFF AT MAR-A-LAGO?
WHY DID HE HAVE THAT STUFF AT
MAR-A-LAGO?
WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT.
UNTIL WE DO, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
KNOW THE FULL STORY.
PHIL MUDD, THANKS AS ALWAYS.